just 26 more days until the return of
the bachelor and a et I cannot wait the
new bachelor Nick violence my pic all
along and now we are getting our first
look at the interesting ladies we're
gonna be fighting from that rose so
let's break it down by the numbers I am
your new bachelor for Nick season it
seems brunettes have all the fun
21 out of the 30 women competing for
that final rose have dark locks I'm
killing it Nick is 36 but only three of
the women are in their 30s the oldest
age is 31 the youngest are these 23 year
olds hopefully the producers know me
well enough that they'll find some women
who were a good match for each other
right now right now and this is
refreshing
most of these ladies are career women
eight or in the medical field including
several nurses and a Duloc four on their
own business I like someone who can keep
up with me and keep me on my toes and
challenge me and isn't afraid to call me
out on some of my BS there's also an
attorney
flight attendant a chef and an NBA
dancer but it wouldn't be the bachelor
without at least one eyebrow raising
profession meet Alexis who's an aspiring
dolphin trainer but maybe she needs to
study a little harder because Alexis
shows up on night one dressed as a shark
sworn enemy of the dolphin there are
more sneak peek photos from the premiere
and props to Laci who showed up riding a
camel
[Music]
you